we realized kind of intellectually that
to a certain degree the way we think
about this planet whether that's water
on the planet life on the planet
resources on the planet we tend to think
about it from the very much from the
context of the surface of a
2-dimensional pale blue dot and we
realized that if we could transform our
way of thinking about the planet to
really encompass the challenges of
three-dimensional science of thinking
about what the subsurface means
in terms of exploration for life
understanding subsurface life
understanding water resources
understanding the distribution of other
fluids and gases in the crust that this
could potentially transform how we think
about the earth but most importantly as
well shed light then on how we might
think about exploring other worlds one
thing that stood out is that the surface
of Mars is a hostile place it is dry
cold and it's bad radiation so where
would you want to be if you were microbe
or any form of life you'd want to be
underground is is the philosophy so
that's what led me to this partnership
with barb over the last couple of years
because here's where the expertise lies
to really understand what a planet like
Mars should potentially behave like and
so we're transforming the knowledge that
we're learning from the earth and trying
to fit that into the what we understand
about Mars there are not a lot of
mechanisms to really allow that much
free thinking and interdisciplinarity
and I think it is that that CFR is going
to be particularly catalytic for us to
be able to bring together people from
extremely different perspectives and
then give them that intellectual freedom
to challenge each other challenge
themselves to change the thinking having
life in this deep long-term ground water
on Earth is just opening up an entire
field of science that we did not know to
exist ten years ago and so what does it
mean I think we're still trying to map
that at but in terms of a whole aspect
of biology that was unknown and how it
affects the surface how it affects the
interior how how biology actually
works within these tight limits is
really the importance of what's going on
with the life underground
[Music]
you